I know that you're indeed documentaries
I love document yeah that's probably my
favorite thing to check out on Netflix
or anything like that well there's an
incredible new documentary coming out
about mountain climbing and I think it
just came out and it's called mountain a
lot of people are talking about this
yeah the film it's a here's what makes
it different than a lot of other films
the film was shot by cinematographers
who are also experienced mountain
climbers so the footage is absolutely
epic I bet it's just amazing everyone's
talking about it
I saw it some of the shots are just
breathtaking you just takes your breath
away which is you know the definition of
breathtaking anyway but then there are
some shots I'm sorry that to me just
didn't feel authentic at all and that
took me out I really move you a little
bit yeah I'll let you be the judge this
is the trailer and you see if you can
spot anything
[Music]
[Applause]
one more anchor point then we're good to
go
[Applause]
hey dumb oh please don't do that go go
Jew can we just stop this must look so
fake yeah you're probably right
[Applause]
well crap somebody help me get Jim
hard to say yeah
you